Peter Parker is getting some slick new
duds in spider-man's second solo outing
in the Marvel Cinematic Universe in
December 2018
Brazil's Comic Con experience played
host to a splashy rollout for the
homecoming follow up one of the most
exciting surprises was a new black
spider suit built for stealth which
we'll get to see in action when
Spiderman far from home seized release
in July 2019
this won't be the first time we've
gotten to see Peter Parker rock and
upgraded outfitted in the MCU in
spider-man homecoming the first
standalone feature for Tom Hollands
version of the wall crawler the
burgeoning hero initially wore a lo-fi
homemade soup before slipping into the
high-tech outfit Tony Stark designed for
him at the time that suit was the most
technologically advanced outfit we'd
ever seen spider-man where on screen
with flash and flair and an AI assistant
to rival Iron Man's armor hey shoot lady
I kinda feel bad calling you soup lady
you know but while Tony Stark played a
big part in spider-man homecoming it
doesn't look as though the character
will be appearing at all and far from
home the absence of Iron Man has led
some fans to conclude that Avengers in
game will mark mr. stark swan song but
we're not too sure about that yet a lot
needs to be explained in the MCU story
between now and far from homes release
like how exactly Peter is going to be
coming back to life to be honest this
whole movie should come with the spoiler
alert instead of an assist from Stark
Industries
it looks like far from home will instead
feature Peter getting some help from
former shield agents Maria Hill and Nick
Fury and considering their super spy
bona fides they may well have had a hand
in getting Peter his sleek new stealth
suit in stark contrast to the ultra
high-tech iron spider suit featured in
Avengers infinity war the stealth suit
features a decidedly more low-tech
aesthetic blurry photos of the new suit
have been circulating around the
internet since far from home started
filming but now we've got the first
official look at the new duds the photo
shows spider-man star Tom Hollands
suited up in the sleek costume perched
on what looks like the edge of a window
the new black suit has almost no
resemblance to the classic black
symbiote suit and it's also much more
low-tech than the stealth suit from the
spider-man ps4 game this take on the
stealth suit looks to be composed of a
fine mesh under layer with
several tactical accessories there's a
black jacket like chess piece complete
with a visible zipper and eye pieces in
the classic Spyder shape it also
features thigh pads Shen high boots
fingerless gloves and spiffy black web
shooters in an interesting turnaround
from the iron spider suit this getup
actually looks like something a
well-funded teenager could put together
for themselves which should be a boon to
hopeful cosplay enthusiasts beyond the
new black super suit we don't know a
great deal about what's going to go down
and far from home we know that a great
deal of the story will be taking place
in Europe far away from Spidey's typical
haunts of Queens and Manhattan hence the
title and we also know that Jake
Gyllenhaal will be taking on the young
Avenger as the nefarious trickster
villain Mysterio but beyond those broad
ideas very few actual plot details have
emerged about the movie meaning that it
isn't clear what kind of sneaky missions
might necessitate the new threats will
spider-man be sneaking into some secret
facility or will he be slinging himself
around European vistas while in hiding
from his enemies for now it's up in the
air well we don't know what the suit
will be for exactly the inspiration for
the suits design seems clear the stealth
suit bears more than a passing
resemblance to the outfit worn by a
character named spider-man waar an
alternate universe version of spider-man
who's appeared in both the comic books
and the Sony animated feature spider-man
into the spider-verse
but enough about the new black suit
what's going on with Peters default
outfit in October 2018 Tom Hollands
showed off a revamped version of his
classic homecoming suit during an
appearance on Jimmy Kimmel Live it's a
fairly simple redesign swapping out the
blue portions of the original suit for
black the stealth version on the other
hand is like nothing we've ever seen
Spidey wear on screen before even the
black symbiote suit from Sam Raimi's
spider-man 3
but while spider-man's outfit is going
dark again we're pretty sure he'll be
keeping his sunny personality this time
around a dark and gritty spider-man that
sounds like the last thing audiences
want activating instant kill no no no no
no I don't want to kill anybody